a
commencer demain au Québec. Il y
a apparemment une prise de
rendez-vous. Je vous rappelle
qu'il y a 150 000 enfants de cet
âge Québec. Pardon, 650 000.
Dr Alex Carignan, membre du
Comité sur l'immunisation dududu
Québec, microbiologiste-
infectiologue à la Faculté de
médecine et des sciences de la
santé de l'Université de
Sherbrooke.
Les enfants ne sont pas malades
pourquoi ils se faire vacciner?
- Les enfants sont largement
épargnés par exemple il n'y a
pas eu de décès chez les cinq à
11 ans. Par contre il y a
d'autres problèmes de santé liés
à la copie 19. Problème
inflammatoire, des symptômes de
COVID-19 persistante.Difficulté,
des problèmes d'essoufflements
qui peuvent persister mais aussi
tous les problèmes sociaux. Il y
a un paquet d'écoles qui sont
fermées en raison des éclosions
de COVID-19. Les enfants mêmes
en 2022, près de deux ans aprèss
le début de la pandémie qui sont
encore reconfinement et j'en
sais quelque chose parce que ma
fille et reconfinement en raison
d'une éclosion dans sa classe.
Donc il y a de nombreuses
raisons de vouloir faire
vacciner nos enfants.
- Sur une base collective, si
les enfants se fer à
60 %, ça va améliorer notre
protection collective pour tout
le monde?
- C'est difficile d'avoir un
chiffre magique. C'est clair que
la vaccination des enfants est
un point important pour nous
rapprocher de cette fameuse
té collective. Est-ce
qu'on l'atteindre? Ce n'est pas
certain en raison du variant
Delta mais éclaire plus la
vaccination progresse, si on
ajoute cela avec des adultes noa
maladie, on se rapproche d'une
masse critique et ça devient
beaucoup plus difficile pour lui
de se frayer un chemin dans la
population.- Comment sait-on qun
est sécuritaire puisqu'il est
nouveau? - Oui, ça, c'est une
très bonne question. Je pense
que c'était primordial
d'répondre. Les effets
secondaires bénins qu'on voit à
peu près avec tous les vaccin
qu'on a vu avec la vaccination
chez les adultes. On parle de
douleurs aussi d'injection, des
maux de tête et de la fièvre
mais des symptômes qui sont
généralement bénins qui vont
partir spontanément. Qu'on avait
davantage de questions, c'est au
niveau des effets secondaires
plus graves comme l'myocardite.
L'influ niveau du coeur
qui est un effet secondaire rare
qu'on a vu chez les jeunes
et 24 ans. Les
problèmes études chez les
enfants ne nous ont pas montré
de cas il y avait somme toute
peu d'enfants. Par contre,
j'étais heureux de voir qu'onavr
rapport aux États-Unis avec
l'homologation de vaccin parce
qu'aux États-Unis, on vaccinait
depuis quelques semaines et en a
maintenant près de 3 millions
d'enfants vaccinés et on n'a pas
vu d'émergence de signal sur la
myocardite. C'est extrêmement
rassurant et il y a d'autres
données de vaccination chez les
de la santé sont encourageants.
À l'heure actuelle, je me sens
tout à fait ner
les enfants et de vacciner mes
propres enfants.
- Voyant les données de la
vaccination aux États-Unis, vous
êtes tellement rassuré que vous
allez faire vacciner votre
propre fille.
- Oui, ans à
son rendez-vous pour samedi à 13
heures. Et ma plus vieille de 12
deuxième dose
nc nous sommes
très heureux. Nous espérons que
ça va aider aussi à lutter les e
mentionnais, l'école qui est
fermée pour mes enfants à des
impacts aussi pour nos enfants.
- Il n'y a pas de différence
entre cinq jusqu'à 11 ans. Suite
non, je vous dirai qu'est-ce
qu'on a vu dans les études, ces
similaires en termes d'effets
secondaires. C'est généralement
bien tolérée. Suite il y a des
contre-indications? Les parents
qui me posent des questions. Un
enfant qui a de l'asthme par
exemple.
- Je vous dirai que j'encourage
la vaccination d'un enfant qui a
de l'asthme. On sait que
l'asthme bien contrôlé pour être
déstabilisé par une infection
contre la copie 19. Les contre-
indications au vaccin sont les
mêmes que chez l'adulte entre
autres les allergies à deux
composantes spécifiques vaccin.
Mais quand même il y a des
contre-indications qui demeurent
vraiment rarissimes.
- En terminant, Docteur, va voir
un tableau de du pourcentage de
la population vaccinée au
Canada. Par rapport à l'Europe
et malheureusement on constate
qu'en Europe même s'ils ont un
taux de vaccination, les Pays-
Bas, 73 %, 69 % en France et 67
% en Allemagne, en Autriche
Allemagne France Pays-Bas, les
cas sont repartis. Nous sommes
plus vaccinés, oui, mais pas
tant que ça plus.
- Je vous dirai que les 10 % ont
un impact important entre autres
États-Unis et on a pu voir les
proportions vaccination dans
différents états, il y avait une
grande disparité et ça amenait
aussi une grande disparité au
niveau des cas il n'y a pas
uniquement la vaccination, il y
a aussi les différentes mesures
encore en place. Au Québec on
est beaucoup plus libre qu'on
pouvait l'être mais quand même,
il y a certaines mesures
maintenues.
- Contrairement à l'Europe où on
est plus tassé. Alors la vague
européenne, est-ce que vous la
craignez?
- La copie 19, on a appris à
craindre. Il faut s'intéresser à
ce qui se passe en Europe mais
je suis quand même plus
confortable dans notre siège
avec le taux de vaccination et
le début de la vaccination chez
les cinq à 11 ans. En France, on
ne débute pas tout de suite la
vaccination des cinq à 11 ans ça
aussi, ça risque de rendre
l'automne plus difficile en
France.
- Et Silvi vont, les enfants,
est-ce qu'en janvier, février,
on peut revenir? Monsieur
Legault a dit : je n'aurais pas
dû faire un lien direct entre
vacciner les jeunes et la
liberté totale.
- On l'espère et on l'attend et
je pense que c'est toujours un
peu difficile. Parfois Monsieur
Legault s'est fait prendre à
faire des promesses donc
effectivement je pense qu'on
s'approche d'un point tournant.
Il y a plusieurs étapes dans
cette lutte à la pandémie on
approche une étape qui pourrait
nous donner des résultats très
intéressants. D'abord la
vaccination se fait pour le
bénéfice individuel des enfants
mais ça va avoir un impact
comment mentionné au niveau
collectif.
merci beaucoup. D'ici quelques
semaines, ça va faire deux ans
qu'on se parle.
- C'est incroyable. Je
réfléchissais justement la
semaine dernière de tout le
chemin parcouru depuis deux ans.